Black Friday New York City eager
shoppers in search of the Knicks bargain
are unaware that they're about to become
the first victims of the biological
attack that will spread throughout the
country across the world
by the time symptoms of the virus are
noticed it's already too late to prevent
the pandemic tira ensues borders are
closed streets towns and eventually
whole cities are quarantined public
services like transportation electricity
and water facilities begin to break down
along with the supply chains for food
and medicine followed closely behind the
gradual collapse of the government the
division story is supported by a
backdrop of real world cities and no
detail is spared given how lifelike
these cities look you can't help but
wonder there's an attack like that's
possible would it destroy saya tea so
quickly and could the division story
actually happen in real life
[Music]
you
in the world of tom clancy's of the
division it was dr. Gordon Amherst who
created the dollar flu the virus was
made up by piecing together over a dozen
different diseases and combining them
with the original smallpox virus this
was achieved by digitizing the DNA and
using 3d printed technology which
subsequently created the deadly new
super disease official reports only talk
of her a most spent time working in
Russian labs alongside duct of the telly
Tanika and although it stated that M
host acquired the original smallpox
strains from an unknown source it
wouldn't be unreasonable to assume that
he managed to commandeer some samples
during his time at the labs all that he
had his friend Vitaly nip on down and
grab a bottle of smallpox while he was
on his way back from the supermarket one
day during the 20th century alone it's
estimated that smallpox was responsible
for 300 to 500 million deaths it was one
of the deadliest diseases in history and
it took humanity decades and cost
billions of dollars to finally have it
declared as eradicated in December 1979
only two facilities in the world are
authorized to hold samples of smallpox
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention in the United States and the
victor Institute in Russia while these
samples are under lockdown there are
constant lobbyists calling for the
destruction of the final traces of the
disease that crippled mankind so with
this in mind I can't imagine it's
particularly easy to just mosey on by to
one of these facilities and grab a
sample of the virus even if you're
working there or we're reasonably high
up I'm sure there are procedures in
place and their inventory is most likely
regularly being audited by the World
Health Organization nevertheless as the
story in the division goes but looks
like Amherst was potentially helped
along by people higher up in the food
chain and we're able to bypass some of
these procedures put in place however in
the real world this is well I would say
unlikely but less likely
so if the last remaining samples of the
virus locked away in labs and opposite
sides of the earth you think that would
be it right there is no way or a very
slim chance of the division story ever
happening I mean we can't even get our
hands on the first ingredient so what if
I told you you could just make a
synthetic version of smallpox from
scratch well some Canadian researchers
did just that in 2017 a team lead by
virologist David Evans of the University
of Alberta we're able to create horsebox
a close relative of smallpox with very
little specialized knowledge at a cost
of around $100,000 and only six months
work the synthesized horse pox virus was
made from genetic pieces that will
brought in via mail order now horse box
is not known to harm humans but using
the same techniques there is no doubt
that smallpox could be created so there
must be some regulations in place
regarding the supply of such genetic
materials especially when it comes to
previously eradicated diseases well yes
producing viruses in this fashion would
be prohibited under World Health
Organization regulations labs are not
allowed to make more than 20% of the
smallpox genome and the companies that
make and sell DNA fragments have
voluntary checks in place to prevent
their customers from ordering
ingredients for certain pathogens unless
they have valid reason but it's also
been recognized for a number of years
that controlling every company in the
world that produces nucleic acids is
impossible to quote David Evans the
world just needs to accept the fact that
you can do this and now we have to
figure out what is the best strategy for
dealing with it to sum up a sample of
the smallpox virus may not be obtainable
from the two known facilities that
currently house it but the DNA sequence
of smallpox as well as other potentially
dangerous pathogens such as poliovirus
and 1918 flu are freely available in
online public databases so to build a
virus from scratch also on we need is to
order consecutive lengths of DNA along
the sequence and glue them together in
the correct order
now this is obviously beyond the skills
and equipment of the kitchen chemists
but it could be achieved by a
well-funded terrorist with access to a
basic lab and PhD level personnel so we
now have the smallpox virus or a
synthetic version of it anyway but
smallpox alone although devastating
wouldn't be enough to bring down society
firstly smallpox only has a mortality
rate of 30 percent and secondly it has a
long incubation period of around two
weeks this would take too long for the
virus to spread and in Game two weeks
had passed and society already begun to
collapse as a story tells us the virus
had some help Amherst created the dollar
flu with traces of swine flu Ebola
dengue hantavirus and Marburg it also
mentions later on that over a dozen
other viruses were added to the mix just
for good measure although some of these
were just added for fictional shock
value some would certainly have added to
the levels of mortality and shortened
the time at which the virus would become
infectious for example Haunter is very
stable and easy to disseminate and the
flu would have aided in shortening the
incubation period in the story empress
uses a 3d DNA printer to perfect a super
virus but in the real world this isn't
something that's readily available the
technology is being worked on but it
certainly isn't an estate where it can
be purchased over the counter but even
without that technology modern
biochemists are able to create diseases
and vaccines by sequencing the disease
and removing or adding proteins as they
wish experts in the field tell us that
if you sequence the proteins and
diseases mentioned above which cause
death and then combine them all into a
single virus you would have a disease
there's the potential to kill very
quickly
so why did Amherst choose smallpox as
the base for a super virus
well for starters small boxes and
eradicated virus so medical personnel
would lift likely be able to identify
this straightaway but also Amex for a
pretty good story a long since destroyed
virus that has come back to wipe out
humanity however there's also no
treatment for those who have already
been infected only a dated vaccine it's
also incredibly easy to spread via
coughing or sneezing or clothing and of
course water dollar bills made of their
75% cotton and 25% linen which also
accounts for most clothing so from
spreading the disease point of view
smallpox is essentially a very favorable
virus to work from needless to say there
are much smarter people than I who
specialized in science writing and who
have done the mathematics on the
scenario that has played out in game
hank campbell an award-winning science
writer and bit selling author has run
the figures that went down in new york
city following the biological attack he
states that it comes down to how many
bills to use not enough and the disease
can easily be isolated or died off also
taking into account that most people
these days are increasingly using credit
cuts the chances of success are improved
dense populations and very little
biodiversity which pretty much sums up
Manhattan so Black Friday and a densely
populated area for people the ones who
are most susceptible in a health crisis
are going shopping because they need the
money to go further and they're more
likely to use cash gamble worked out
that the year before the endgame Black
Friday 2014 the department store who in
the real world was Macy's Manhattan it's
sixteen thousand people visit from 5:00
p.m. until closing
nine days after Black Friday two-thirds
of Manhattan had been evacuated and 48%
of those left behind were infected by
the time that the game starts on January
6th around 300,000 people have already
died with this information Campbell was
able to come up with the number using
the following formula which is
transmissibility multiplied by the rate
of contact between susceptible and
infected individuals by the duration of
infectiousness this allowed him to
create a pretty valid susceptible
infected removed or SAR model because
Manhattan is an island and generally
people shopping in Manhattan live in
Manhattan a long complicated story short
campbell was able to work out that
macy's Abel's would have had to move
almost a hundred thousand bills in that
short period of time and even worth
16,000 people going through there
this figure is highly unlikely so the
way that M has chose to disperse the
virus and game simply would not work out
in the real world he would have to think
bigger in terms of releasing the
infected notes a whole block of shops or
an entire mall for example
so let's say we now have a super virus
and we've dispersed it through the
appropriate channels to have it spread
among the American population how would
we react to such a situation those of
you who have delved deep into the
division will be aware that the writers
of the story have actually drawn from a
wealth of information and scientific
data and that the way things played out
in game was a surprisingly authentic
representation of what could actually
happen in real life over the last few
decades scientific assessments of the
risk of a pandemic have viewed the
threat with increasing seriousness it's
now widely recognized that our societies
are completely unprepared but the
interesting thing is that it's not the
biological attack that will bring down
society but industrial civilization
itself before the release of the game
Ubisoft commissioned the French firm B
et Cie to create a software tool
collapse the end of society simulator
this tool would help create the scenario
for the game summing it up your patient
zero all you have to do is type in your
address and the simulator does the rest
the virus user in the simulator is the
smallpox super virus used in game with a
seven day incubation period and a
mortality rate of 90% the simulator uses
open source information on over 5,000
cities on population densities hospital
and bit numbers connection between
cities in the rest of the world as well
as other real world data shortly after
giving your location you'll run through
the steps of what is about to play out
by day for your starting to fail ill be
visible and in turn and fix of people
day6 the vaccines run out supermarkets
are virtually empty and fights begin to
break out over whatever's left the
government is forced to declare a state
of emergency day 9 over two million are
now infected and the death toll is over
400 thousand law enforcement can no
longer contain the riots and martial law
is declared in major cities by day 22
half a billion people have died with 1.4
billion infected energy infrastructure
communication systems and supply chains
fail military chains of command begin to
break down by day 24 the world as we
know it is collapsed in 2006 the US
Department of Homeland Security issued a
guide on pandemic preparedness which
warned the mounting risk of a worldwide
influenza pandemic poses numerous
potentially devastating consequences for
critical infrastructure in the United
States a pandemic will likely reduce
dramatically the number of available
workers in all sectors and significantly
disrupt the movement of people and goods
which will threaten essential services
and operations state local and tribal
jurisdictions will be overwhelmed and
unable to provide or ensure the
provision of essential commodities and
services it goes on to state that a
pandemic could also cause significant
economic and security ramifications
potentially including large-scale social
unrest
due to fear of infections or concerns
about safety other consequences are
likely to include international military
conflict increased terrorist activity
internal unrest political and/or
economic collapse humanitarian crisis
and dramatic social change the division
story also takes inspiration from a
real-world scenario called Operation
duck winter a military simulation based
on a covert smallpox terrorist attack on
the United States carried out in June
2001
exercises like dark winter eventually
led to the Bush administration to bust
the national security and Homeland
Security presidential directive
otherwise known as directive 51 which
contains annex is so classified even
members of Congress on the Homeland
Security Committee are denied access to
them directive 51 s purpose is to
maintain continuity of government in the
event of a catastrophic emergency
defined as any incident regardless of
location that results in extraordinary
levels of mass casualties damage or
disruption severely affecting the u.s.
population infrastructure environment
economy or government functions he
grants the president trakone Ian powers
including the suspension of all
elections the complete subordination of
federal and local government departments
to the executive branch and the
extension of military command into
civilian life the unknown content of
directive 51 s classified annexes is the
perfect scenario for the divisions world
of covert operations and top secret
agencies to sum up we are incredibly
unprepared for a scenario like this and
the way that the division is played out
regarding the speed and collapse of
society it is a very good representation
of what could actually happen
in conclusion could the division story
actually happen with a few small tweaks
I believe yes and the scary thing is
that it could be done with relative ease
and worse still if it was done secretly
would have no idea what was happening
and - it was too late so this video was
just a small taste of the depth so wind
and do with this research I found it so
interesting that I just kept on digging
but when I got to the point of finding
contact details of where I could order
genetic samples from and how a
bioterrorist could have done the job
even more efficiently using an even more
straightforward method in water supplies
I thought to myself maybe I'm getting
too deep so to reduce the risk of
incriminating myself any further I
decided that I should cull a fair amount
of the information that I was going into
as it is my internet search history over
the last two weeks is likely to get me a
knock on the door from men in suits so
if I go quiet you'll know what happened
the intention of this video is not to
freak people out I just found it
incredibly interesting and thought
others might too as knowledge really is
key I thoroughly enjoy being able to
relate Tom Clancy titles to the real
world and incidentally this one just
felt a little too close to home
maybe the developers of the division
we're intending the game to be more of a
training simulator than a place to shoot
dogs and play dress-up dolls either way
I think I need to check up on my
emergency kit and maybe expand on the
basic supplies to last us for a few more
days anyway I hope you found this as
interesting as I did thank you very much
for watching and I'll catch you in the
next one
hopefully Cheers
you